i'm getting ready to like really get
into the thick of making my album
um i'm just like i just want to make
sure people feel that same energy i want
them to feel that stink
and that bass and rust we always talk
about like the blessing and
gift of being able to do life together
and just how special that is but also
being able to impact together i feel
like i'm my most confident
self that i've ever been serving look
starts on the inside it's more than a
manicure
getting our hair done or a new outfit
taking care of our health
inside and out sierra you're doing some
important work out here
you've collaborated with the black
women's health imperative and project
health equality
for a campaign called serving confidence
tell us about it
well i'm excited to be a part of this
amazing campaign and
i think there's a huge opportunity to
impact many lives
to maybe even save lives and especially
in
especially for my black women um you
know obviously being a black woman when
i
heard about the opportunity to be a part
of this amazing campaign i
was super excited um you know i also got
to educate myself in the process and
when i learned that black women are two
times more likely to die from cervical
cancer
i was taken aback but also super
compelled to
use my platform it's time for this to no
longer be the case and it's really
simple for us i think the conversation
around
around well-woman exams are always a
little
funny i don't know what it is about this
thing but it's just always kind of like
and i don't really know like not there's
probably not one woman that's had this
feeling at some point time in their life
there's just something about it
but i'm like let's make this actually an
exciting moment like let's make this
a tradition or standard
standard thing that we do in our lives
especially as
women of color you know black women have
been
uh disproportionately affected by
cervical cancer as well as hispanic
women
and so i think there's just a huge
opportunity to really make a difference
here and to change the narrative it's
it's really time
yeah and the huge part about it is that
it's preventative
you know i didn't have a great ob gyn
who was on me about the hpv vaccines
and just staying on top of that i don't
know what could have happened in my
situation
you know yes 100 percent i think that's
also what's really amazing is
you know when you learn about it it is
preventative
and that's why it's so important that we
make our well well woman exams and
you know we get our pap screening and
hpv screening and
you know that we're on top of this stuff
you know it's it's huge
you know i think self-care is the best
care and this is a big part of it
so let's know like the amazingness that
we behold
and let's take care of it what actually
inspired
you to be a part of it i know you said
it came to your table but what's
what in you said okay well yeah my
someone on my team had cervical cancer
and she actually overcame it and um
you know so i was really connected to it
um
you know and she actually she wasn't a
black woman but
you know it was a woman obviously and
and for me
um you know when i learned about that
information
or when i knew what i experienced with
her
and seeing her go through her process
and having her faith keeping her faith
strong
um you know and knowing how really
understanding the disparity you know
that black women are two times more
likely to
die from cervical cancer like understand
that made me say i have to get out
and i have to share this message like i
need to inform
all my black queens around the world to
know you know
know this and to know we can change this
like it's really simple it's just about
us like knowing the information
going out making our scheduling our paps
scheduling our exams
and just simply simple as that so i
think for me
you know i always just propel because
again i just know this opportunity to
save someone's life
we're really doing some generational
work out here um
you're doing serving confidence making
sure we stay on top of our health
you and russell just opened up the why
not you academy how would you explain
this
time in your life and your career
you know it's an exciting time i think
this is a huge opportunity
to you know uh really make a difference
in many ways
and i i just i what i'm really proud of
is that a lot of the like big visions
and dreams that
i had and in this case both of us and i
have shared are happening
um there's just no greater feeling than
experiencing that and
we always talk about like the blessing
and gift of being able to do life
together
and just how special that is but also
being able to impact together
it's just it's it's incredible it's an
incredible feeling
um and you know it's just been amazing
to do all these things together and with
the why not you academy
you know we got the opportunity to go to
the to the school location last week
and surprise a couple of students and
staff and
to see their reaction on their faces
were just it was just so touching but
also hear them talk about how proud they
were too
on being founding students of the yniu
academy and how much hope they had
and the success of their future and just
you know all they want to do
like it was just beyond touching and i
was like this is why we do this like
there's so much opportunity to change
someone's life in the course of their
life so
think about it if someone had the
opportunity education like who knows how
damaging that could be but knowing that
they have the opportunity
um to further their education can create
a new legacy for their family and
their their kids kids and so it's kind
of the gift that keeps on giving
and it's just one that we're super
charged about and
impact is at the center or or at the
forefront of everything that we do
and so we're it's been amazing to do it
all together it's really fun
you can tell you two are really purpose
partners there's a lot to admire about
your relationship but i think
that's one of the things that stand out
to me you know because marriage
is not just about well i don't know i'm
not married yet but what i
see it's not just about oh this is my
husband or my wife it's how can we come
together
and make the world better and you two
are definitely doing that
so sweet thank you so much
is such a rich hub for african-american
talent so i'm curious
how has the city shaped you as an artist
oh my gosh you know atlanta is a big
part of what's made me who i am today
and i think it's just this special
atlanta has a special culture
it's like its own thing it's its own
vibe and historically
some of the best music musicians
creators that have come from atlanta and
i think it's just something in water
something in the water as they would say
um in atlanta and you know that flavor
you can't
you can't fabricate you can't create
that like it's just
it's in the air and and when you get a
taste of it
it does it will change your life yes i
love that
well i want to talk about your goodies
era because it was
everything
[Music]
the other day and the the interviewer
she had
no other option but say see era you know
you just have
how was that era for you like looking
back now
what was it like if you could describe
it oh my gosh that air was pretty
amazing
um definitely unforgettable i'm
definitely a very pivotal moment in my
life
and um you know it was moving so fast
you know it was pretty amazing to have
you know three top
three songs and have a number one hit on
the billboard guitar and the number one
song globally
um and to have some of the top songs
globally that was pretty
crazy to just be like 18 19 years old
experiencing all of that
but it definitely um you know it
definitely was a part of cementing my
foundation as an artist
you know and um even when i look back to
those times and just like it's amazing
to
uh reflect on the journey you know and
like to
to be here 17 years later from that
album is kind of
trippy to me and still feeling like i
have
so much more opportunity it's really a
blessing
i'm getting ready to start you know as
i'm getting ready to like really get
into the thick of making my album
um i'm just like i just want to make
sure people feel that same energy i want
them to feel that sustain
and that base i want to turn them up
when they listen to the records i want
them to want to dance
i want them to feel all that good stuff
so i'm excited yeah what about missy
elliot is there i know you all
collaborated after one two steps a few
times but
is there any chance that we can see a
collaboration again you know
i think me and missy always have to get
together so you know you never know what
we'll do um
but every time he gets together it's
always special always so
i'm always down for having miss join me
on a record and vice versa
yeah and this new album when can fans
expect it i know you're busy with family
life and everything your career has
blossomed into but
when can we expect it you know you know
my fans always hate when i say stay
tuned so i won't say that
but i'll just say that you know what
it's
coming along really good the whole
process the project and
you know i definitely want to pick the
perfect timing to give it to my fans i
want to make sure i have everything in
line
the way that i envision it to come to
life and i can't wait till that moment
is here and
as soon as i have that date i will make
sure to like put it out there for my
fans so
i'm excited looking forward to it so in
five weeks from now
i'm gonna check with you guys i'm gonna
be down 10 pounds and i'm going to deal
with my wwe plan
dubbed up club baby so let's go let's go
you should
39 pounds on your wwe journey
how has the snapback felt this time
around
oh my gosh i felt so proud i've always
felt proud but it took me a little
longer to get here than before
um so it was a huge accomplishment for
me you know i um
the last 10 pounds were the hardest so i
made a challenge for myself and just
like
commit to every detail in the process
make sure i'm eating right following my
good regimen on the wwe program
um you know also drinking a lot of water
and just making sure i'm like getting up
and being
you know really active um daily
to just stay on top of the whole
combination and um
you know i'm really proud and especially
having three babies now and working and
doing everything
um definitely makes me feel like super
mom makes me feel like a super woman
yeah i'm curious how has your
relationship changed with your body
over the years um you know i feel like
i'm my most confident self that i've
ever been
yeah i feel like i'm um you know i just
embraced like even when i was losing my
weight i really embraced the whole
process like
i liked i loved every bit of the curve
that was happening along the way
i was like i'm not trying to lose all
the curve now you know like you know
when i was
in my basement i'm like i love that i
love the woman in me like
those you know attributes are part of
like what makes to me what makes me the
makes me a woman
and makes us women you know and so like
even my flaws my tummy will never be the
same i'll never
have the same kind of abs that i had
seven years ago
some people will never have those ads oh
my gosh
i mean it's it's it's it hasn't been the
easiest but
um you know i i really love where i am i
really really feel good about where i am
as a woman
speaking of that baby nguyen is almost
won this is a huge milestone birthday do
you have any plans yet
yeah we've been talking about i just
feel like when is like a super baby like
he's like super win like he legit is 11
months going on 11 years old
um and so i think whatever it is i just
want him to be able to just
let all that energy out like he is so
non-stop
and so i'm like he needs a little
obstacle course of something so we're
going to see what we end up doing you
know i i also look forward to him doing
the cake smash
that's always fun you know to see the
kids make a big little mess of the cake
future didn't really want any parts
doing a cake smash sienna
pretty she she kind of went in a little
bit and i think wins gonna go all the
way in
yeah and i can't wait for that moment i
gotta get my smash cake and the real
cake